welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host better called paul and this
episode we're breaking down the life and
times of saul goodman in his latest
episode titled breaking bad this sees
the titular character go from black and
white to walter white
and there's a there's a lot to unpack in
the episode now we watch jimmy develop a
new identity see what buzz has been up
to since home alone and get more views
than a cat video throughout this we're
going to be going through it all but
we'd massively appreciate you hitting
the thumbs up button and also don't
forget to subscribe for videos like this
every day without the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into better
call saul
[Music]
okay so this episode features the return
of both brian cranston and aaron paul in
the first of their many rumored cameos
this season they're meant to be
returning a couple more times so expect
to see them pop up next week and
probably at some point in the finale
also shout out to all you guys for
sending me a clip from breaking bad
season five in which seoul actually
foreshadows what happens to him in the
series if i'm lucky month from now best
case scenario i'm managing a cinnabon in
omaha now we opened in the build up to
the scene from season 2 in which
sulphurs mentioned lalo and nacho
balo didn't send you
oh thank god oh christ walt and jesse
even ask him about who this is bringing
everything full circle from this prequel
into the show now we see the other side
of it this time with us watching the
events through the eyes of saul as he
travels in the back of the rv10 meth lab
there's also little bullet holes in the
door and it's great being back in this
environment i love how jimmy constantly
speaks spanish as he believes that the
cartel have finally caught up with him
whatever the problem
we can fix it with daenerys
are they leaning over the grey that
they've dug out for him and there
becomes some very important symbolism
with this later on we transition from
the grave to gene lying in bed and the
images are superimposed over the top of
each other to me this potentially
foreshadows that death is coming for
gene and that's right it's theory time
due time dear time
new time with gene technically not
existing there is a possibility that he
could be killed off by some of the
characters in the present-day storyline
and thus no one would ever really go
looking for him sure he's the manager of
cinnabon but beyond that he doesn't have
any friends or relatives and most
believe that he could potentially
already be dead if they unearthed his
body the police would likely instantly
identify who he was and then they'd
probably tie to the cartel in the
opening we get such a strong emphasis on
jaime believing it's the cartel which
may be used as a way to reflect the
police assumptions too now i'd love it
if marion ended up killing him after
discovering who he is last week she
talked about how she and jeff had to
move away from albuquerque because the
ladder got in with the wrong crowd she
spends a lot of time on her computer
watching cat videos and potentially she
might even stumble across a wanted
poster for saul goodman this would make
her realize who jean is and then she
might kill him to protect her son the
pair could then bury him and with him
not technically existing he might get
away with this however this symbolism
could also be used to show the death of
gene as we get soul returning and even a
new identity in this entry might not
happen any of that and i kind of hope
that soul lives but anyway that's the
end of their time here time here time
probably not right so don't don't watch
this video after the finale
now the title sequence is a lot shorter
than normal with us barely getting
anything beyond a brief flash of a
rocking chair we cut to the blue screen
of death that you'd get when a vhs tape
hit a point where nothing had been
recorded onto it i think this shows that
time is running out but jimmy slash saul
slash gene slash victor and whether it's
death or jail things are all coming to a
close now cut to friend also yeah it is
the finale in two weeks time so not a
massive prediction that but still i
think i'll be right in that case now we
could to francesca who seems as sick of
her life as the rest of the characters
are we start off with a cheerio floating
in a blocked sink which reminded me a
lot of the pool scene from breaking bad
with the bear the only good thing in her
life is that she occasionally catches
glimpses of jackie chan adventures on
the tv but other than that her existence
is pretty crappy you might remember that
in season 4 soul told that if he had a
specific pay phone at a specific time
and we watch as she travels out of this
location it appears that she's being
followed and though we don't know if
this is for definite francesca states
that she knows she's being tailed a lot
her phone at home clicks and her mail is
open showing how the feds are still
looking for the characters that got away
we hear about skyler's deal and also how
jesse's car was found at the border
which is something that was touched upon
in el camino hewlett has also moved back
to new orleans as he was held in a false
pretences and he got to walk lastly they
bring up kuby who was played by bill
burr in breaking bad along the way we
see an ad for william oakley on a bench
and this lists him as a defense attorney
showing how he switched sides now at
this point francesca comes to a literal
crossroads this of course symbolizes
someone having to make a choice and it's
something that saul also does later on
in the entry just as she's about to take
off the phone rings and jean speaks to
her there's some great iconography in
this scene such as graffiti of an old
western sheriff hinting to how the law
is always a potential danger we see how
seoul had money hidden away just in case
times got tight and the reason he chose
his pay phone is because it's close to a
bundle of cash we learned that money is
running low as all of his laundering
operations have been compromised by the
feds and these fake friends have left
saul with no reserves saul is also
wearing marco's ring who too gets name
dropped in this entry now along with
this we also hear that kim has asked
whether jimmy is alive or not francesca
didn't give anything up as this could
make it so the police look into her more
if kim snitches now this idea of kim
asking after him scratches away at jimmy
and he eventually rings her after
stopping at a literal crossroads
symbolism again that now this of course
confirms that kim is alive and that she
survived past the events of breaking bad
of course we did kind of know this but
we discovered that she's now working at
a sprinkler company out in florida in
true better call sole fashion we don't
see their conversation however the
emotions that jimmy has are very clear
in an interview with entertainment
weekly the creative team behind the
series brought up that we'll see the
other side of this at some point in the
future and i imagine that next week
might even open with things from kim's
point of view now a big theme about this
season especially is how seoul is
addicted to the lifestyle bob arden kirk
has discussed several times in
interviews how jimmy is constantly
pulled back to the con because that's
who he is as a person he just can't keep
away from it and though he's alive he
doesn't feel like he's living even after
telling jeff that it was over last week
he returns to work with him and buddy
which will likely lead to his demise he
ends up showing marrying cat videos and
though they build some more rapport she
seems really suspicious i don't know if
you've seen the american greed parody
that got posted on jimmy but this
satirical documentary popping up on
youtube would be absolutely hilarious i
think would tie nicely to it and give
marion a way to learn about him and also
protect his son curtis jean running a
con with a man at a barb and for the way
he treated his little brother kevin take
him for all he's worth the guy's a chump
see you chump
a gene sings brandy by the looking glass
which we discover is because he lost to
bet with the character this song always
reminds me of guardians of the galaxy
vol 2 when ego talked about it and i
guess when all you have is comic book
movies then that's your entire frame of
reference for anything what a [ __ ]
loser i am anyway jean is masquerading
under the name of victor which of course
means winner and he plays a sap but he's
just running a long con on him slowly he
drains his drinks to stop him from
getting drunk and allows himself to
constantly lose in order to play him
more and more alfred here is of course
mentor of like marco and i think the
character looks his way on purpose to
mirror him slightly he also pulls off
the cheap cons he did but he's being
played himself so he clearly isn't at
his level jeff arrives in the cab for
the next part of the scam and we see
that buddy is impersonating his dispatch
along with him is a dog that he takes to
the house and this goes with them on all
the jobs that they carry out this way
dogs of course shed hair and potentially
all the jobs could end up getting linked
by this little criminal canine that
accompanies them along the way the
police might end up drawing the
connection and they could go to buddy
and jeff which will scare marion into
maybe giving up the goods on gene now
i'm not going to drop a theory time but
i'm going to keep changing the name of
jimmy throughout the breakdown but again
you know what i mean don't be that guy
in the comments who says well actually
it's it's all not jimmy it's slipping
jimmy you know you know who i mean don't
be that guy you're [ __ ] dead sorry
about that and they take photos i know
you're not oh you're a nice person yeah
they take photos of several documents id
cards bank accounts and checks and this
allows gene to get a swing master
machine which calls back to his time as
seoul go to the breaking bad timeline
and shout out to aaron paul for being in
two of the best shows on tv right now
during this scene seoul figures out that
this is where blue meth is cooked up and
that walter is heisenberg saul grabs the
round bottom flask and talks about how
he could use it as a fishbowl which
links back to the recent poster for this
episode it was great seeing the two back
in this entry and i love how it's not
really played as being just a fan
service cameo and they actually get some
great character moments and lines the
pair bicker back and forth and the
battery ends up running out in the rv
which was of course a big plot point
during breaking bad mike also returns
later on the entry and was it just me or
did this feel like a cameo even though
we only seen him a couple of episodes
ago now he's used to bringing info on
walter white and saul ends up going to
his high school after learning he has
lung cancer after asking about lalo they
try the engine once more which starts up
and from here we transition from the
grave shot into the bed the scam
continues once more with the team
running it on several wealthy men in the
area to the song to powka tundra by mike
nesmoth we watch as they collect several
ids gene beds a lot of ladies of the
night further tying back to his time his
soul telling you anyway he's clearly
back in the first stages of how he used
to operate which eventually led to him
becoming soul the slipping jimmy one is
back and the deck of cards ends up being
set up around a mark who we learn has
cancer this of course reflects walt who
might learn souls shouldn't go near this
conversation is mirrored in the current
scam which there's a lot of talk about
staying away from this is likely the job
that will bring it all crashing down as
buddy wants to stop it but gene wants to
go headfirst into it which may be
foreshadowed in the scene or it may be a
reach now he has no qualms about ripping
someone off with cancer it shows how
much he wants to be in this life at any
cost so a guy with cancer can't be an
[ __ ] huh believe me i speak from
experience gene ends up going to jeff's
in the night which marion overhears and
buddy refuses to do it he also says he
pulled the tape when he left so there's
no way they can do it even if they want
to however jean is too fixated on this
to quit and the pair drive out there and
smash the guy's window love how the
builder for this scene reflects the one
where he was picked up at the airport
but now instead of being paranoid gene
is willing to rush in head first without
any restraint indicate with this is
seoul going past walt's pontiac aztec to
the science department as he breaks the
window looks like stuff is going to go
down too as we know from the preview at
the end that the police arrive and what
this is for i have no idea perhaps buddy
called the cops the guy in the house
might have done it or it could be
someone much worse
jean may have been shot as an intruder
marion might have got a confession from
her son and rang them or jean might have
ended up having to kill the guy which
may have alerted the neighbors i turn it
over to you give us your best theory
below and also let us know what you
think of the episode as a whole i loved
it and i can't wait to see what happens
in the final two i'm guessing next
week's walt cameo will be at the school
and hopefully we'll get a return of kim
as well now as a thank you for posting
below you'll be entered into a
competition where we're giving away
three copies of doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness on the 15th of
august all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the episode you pick the
comments at random at the end of the
month and the winners of the last one
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
westworld which will be linked on screen
right now having a lot of fun with the
show thank you so much for all the
support on it and hopefully i see you
over there right after this by the way
thanks for clicking the video i've been
poor i'll see you next time take care
peace